[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est un acteur dans l'âme il
vit il mange il dort théâtre cinéma
télévision en 60 ans de hier il n'a
jamais arrêté pas une seule fois de
jouer de tourner d'écrire de prêter sa
voix près de 200 rôles partout sur les
planches les plateaux parfois en tant
que réalisateur et metteur en scène
parfois en tant que scénariste aussi
exalté passionné habité acteur à la
puissance 1000 a écrit un jour
libération et il n'a refusé aucun genre
tragique ou comique à toutes les époques
du joueur d'échec de Stepan sik à Jean
Moulin en passant par juste le blanc
dans le dîner de con ou dans les pigeon
sur scène avec Michel LEB vous ne
pourrez jamais lui reprocher ni snobisme
ni élitisme en revanche est-ce pour lui
toujours le même plaisir quel que soit
le rôle est-ce d'ailleurs le même
exercice posonslii toutes ses questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue Francis Huster merci à vous
merci à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation au Sénat dans ce d tournom
est-ce que jouer les pigeons avec Michel
LEB et ou le Misanthrope de Molière
c'est le même exercice pour vous pas du
tout c'estàd c'està-dire que c'est
exactement la différence entre Herbert V
carayan qui qui qui dirige la la la 5e
symphonie
et Charles traet qui chante
ou edit Piaf pourquoi c'est pas le même
exercice parce que le mot clé pour un
acteur c'est le mot
référence c'est-à-dire que quand tu
interprètes des rôles de légendes qui
ont été sublimés dans l'histoire tu dois
absolument ne jamais être en référence à
ce qui s'est fait avant toi et tu dois
au contraire déjà être dans l'avenir si
tu joues ce rôle de légende hamelette
laureno Richard i al et cetera comme
dans le présent on pense qu'il doit être
joué tu commets une erreur faut toujours
le jouer comme personne ne l'a joué
comme on s'attend pas du tout que toi tu
vas l'incarner et être déjà dans
l'avenir donc ça c'est pour les rôles de
légendes alors que par exemple les
pligeons de Michel au contraire c'est
dans le présent c'estd que ancré dans
son époque ancré dans son éc parce que
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre avec le
théâtre la différence entre théâtre et
cinéma c'est que tout le monde dit
toujours ah qu'est-ce qu'il a bien joué
mais non l'acteur il joue pas c'est le
public qui joue ça veut dire que quand
tu es dans la salle alors que les gens
ils peuvent se détester il se parlerent
même pas dans la vie tout le monde tout
d'un coup ne fait qu'une seule même
foule et je disais qu'il y avait aucun
élite me aucun snobisme dans vos choix
de rôle est-ce que c'est vrai on peut le
dire comme ça parce qu'il existe ce
snobisme il y a plein d'acteurs qui
refuseraient de jouer certains rôles
plutôt que d'autres il y a une forme de
de snobisme dans le milieu aussi mais
c'est un tas de faux cul je les je les
déteste depuis des des dizaines d'années
quand j'étais professeur chez Florent
pendant des dizaines d'années j'ai tout
fait pour qu'il comprennent que tu ne
peux pas dire tout d'un coup dans une
foule celui-là non c'est pas non
celui-là qui il a pas de rôle chic et de
rôle honteux mais pas du tout pas du
tout au contraire et c'est juste
justement le problème entre la France
qui est avec depuis tout le temps depuis
Molière depuis le 17e euh il y a une
espèce de de cercle fermé de gens qui
qui se prennent pas pour de la merde et
c'est pour ça que je dis merde parce que
merde c'est pas un nom vulgaire non non
pas du tout tous les jours on a un
rapport avec le pipi avec le caca avec
ça pour moi ces gens-là pensent que les
autres sont inférieurs qui a une
certaine élite allez vous faire voir ce
qui compte au contraire c'est que
comprenez bien dans la salle tu viens tu
tuas eu tous tes problèmes de la vie tu
es là et tout d'un coup tu vas incarner
en cher et en
vibrer en cher et en os avec avec C ses
acteurs et et ses actrices et tu vas
sortir de toi tout d'un coup en tant que
spectateur c'est toi qui devient le roi
moi je sais très bien sur scène que je
suis pas Jul César mais celui dans la
salle où s il se prend pour Cléopatre
Jul César c'est ça la beauté de ce
métier faut bien comprendre faut bien
comprendre vous avez 60 ans de carrière
vous le voyez évoluer ce monde ce métier
ce monde du cinéma ce monde du théâtre
vous envoyez les changements vous avez
dit un jour à mes débuts il y avait
quatre acteurs de pardieu de ver Huster
girudau qui avaient les rôles principaux
et les jeunes jouaient des petits rôles
est-ce qu' aujourd'hui vous avez
l'impression que c'est plus ouvert que
les jeunes acteurs peuvent jouer
davantage plus de rôle aussi mais c'est
extraordinaire aujourd'hui c'està dire
que des jeunes avant à notre époque
d'abord il fallait payer dans les cours
c'est pour ça que François Florent ETI
moi on a créé la classe libre gratuite
sur concours pendant 3 ans où 80 % des
stars d'aujourd'hui sont passés pourquoi
parce que leurs parents ne voulait pas
qu'il devienne comédien ça va comédien
vas-y pu après tu feras un métier voilà
l'image du satinban et il se trouve que
justement aujourd'hui ce qui est
extraordinaire mais ce sont toutes les
plateformes toutes les séries toutes les
tous les les les les séries quotidiennes
où tout d'un coup des jeunes totalement
inconnus ils sont engagés ils sont on 50
dans dans dans la série et ils ont des
vrais rôles principaux c'est veut dire
que tout d'un coup pendant un quart
d'heure c'est vraiment ce jeune comédien
cette jeune comédienne en plus ça leur
donne la possibilité bah de gagner leur
vie d'être tout d'un coup et puis d'être
face à eux-mêmes parce que attends faut
que tu sois bien sinon on te vide de la
série non mais comment vous le trouvez
justement ce jeu des jeunes acteurs vous
qui tenez à distinguez beaucoup de
choses dans vous avez une palette
d'émotion très large vous distinguez la
rage de la colère vous aimez la nuance
et la subtilité dans le jeu d'acteur
est-ce que ces jeunes acteurs que vous
voyez se déployer aujourd'hui dans le
monde du théâtre du cinéma des séries
vous l'avez dit sur les plateformes
notamment vous trouvez que ce jeu est
est subtile est-ce que ou vous y voyez
un appauvrissement du jeu d'acteur du
fait qu'il se développe comme ça mais la
question elle est la même c'est pour ça
qu'on va peut-être passer la soirée
ensemble à parler pendant 3 He du
théâtre c'est que la question est la
même que le sport c'estàdire on va quand
même pas comparer
aujourd'hui les rugbyman les
footballleurs les m mais ils sont 10000
fois plus forts 10000 fois meilleurs que
ceux avant enfin faut c'està-dire que
les acteurs d'aujourd'hui ils ont un
arc-en-ciel d'émotion ils ont tout
compris ils ont des références dont ils
se dégagent justement personne
aujourd'hui pense à imiter Belmondo
Jouvet Gabin et cetera à mon époque tout
ah ça c'est le nouveau ah ça c'est le
nouveau g Philippe ah ça c'est le
nouveau Jouvet ah ça c'est n Gabin et ce
qu'il y a d'extraordinaire et c'est ça
je vous remercie de me poser cette
question c'est
que le le métier de comédien est un
métier religieux c'estàdire que notre
religion à nous c'est la religion des
poètes on est des pratiquants on
pratique ce métier et et on veut faire
en sorte que il n'y ait pas de racisme
il n'y a pas d'islamophobie il y a pas
de d'antisémitisme il n'y ait pas de
tout de il faut bien comprendre que ce
qui est extraordinaire et qui n'était
pas du tout le cas dans les époques
avant aux États-Unis à Hollywood quand
tu étais noir tu étais le chauffeur tu
étais la servante tu étais voilà ton
rôle c'était ça jusqu'à ce que s Poitier
ou aré la fon arrive et qui est un
bouleversement total ce qui est
formidable c'est que tout d'un coup tu
as pas besoin d'être sublimement beau
sublimement belle à 15 ans ou à 16 ans
pour rêver de ce métier vous n'aimeriez
pas qu'on dise d'un jeune acteur tiens
c'est le nouveau Francis Huster surtout
pas c'est-à-dire que le problème c'est
qu'on le dit de beaucoup d' mais mais
non mais mais pour ce qui est nous les
les les quelquesuns dans dans mon cas et
les quelquesunes c'est magnifique si on
le dit dans le sens du parcours
c'est-à-dire expliquer ce qui est un
parcours de comédien dès l'instant où on
admet que les peintres ont trois
couleurs bleu rouge jaune et qu'and les
mélangeons ils font des milliers de
tableaux dès l'instant où on admet que
les musiciens ont do ré mi fa sol la si
c'est tout et ils vont faire des
milliers de de chefdœuvre il faut
comprendre que les comédiens qu'on
méprise dans ce pays et je pèse mes mots
qu'on méprise dans ce pays mais comment
mais attendez qui on mais tous les
gouvernements successifs les uns
derrière les autres tous les ministres
de la Culture les uns derrière les
autres auraientent dû faire des stages
de comédien comprendre ce qu'est un
comédien comprendre ce qui est un
metteur en scène comprenez bien un
comédien c'est quelqu'un qui comme un
musicien ou un peintre a des couleurs
d'âme h on vous a déjà parlé des
couleurs d'âme ceux qui nous écoutent
celles qui nous écoutent on leur a
jamais parler donc ça veut dire que
notre métier c'est pas d'apprendre un
texte notre métier c'est que cette âme
cette âme c'est elle qui interprète
c'est elle qui pousse le corps qu'est-ce
que tu veux c'est ton âme qui t'a fait
faire ça c'est pas le corps qui a
commandé donc ces couleurs d'âme comme
un arcanciel et on va l'épuiser où ces
couleurs d'âme on va l'épuiser dans ses
blessures trs bonne question et bien
c'est la clé peut-être et c'est un peu
ce qui se passe dans notre vie quand on
est justement pas comédien parce que
tout le monde est comédien parce que tu
as des émotions
couleurs d' et parfois en représentation
aussi c'est devant le précipice ou
devant l'escalade ça veut dire h que tu
prends ta vie ta vie ta vraie vie et tu
t'aperçois que tout d'un coup tu t'es
trouvé devant un précipice je saute
dessus cette maladie dessus cette mort
qui me tue dessus dessus ce ce boulot
qu'on m'a foutu à la porte je saute ou
je tombe dans le précipice donc ça c'est
la première possibilité donc tous les
rôles il y a un moment où le rôle est
devant le précipice et à ce moment-là
qu'est-ce qui te fait sauter au-dessus
ou tomber c'est l'émotion tu as cette
espèce d'émotion qui vient je peux tu
tombes mais tu te renforces ce qui fait
que le public est en train de jouer le
rôle ça lui apporte non seulement une
morale de vie mais une force une lumière
extraordinaire qui la transforme
complètement et qu'ouira jamais vous
vous ne vous arrêtez jamais vous jouez
beaucoup je le disais en introduction
comme s'il y avait vous allez me dire si
j'ai tort ou si j'ai raison comme s'il y
avait une sorte de de boulimie en vous
et vous avez dit d'ailleurs un jour je
ne bois je ne bois pas je ne bouffe pas
je je ne prends aucune pilule en fait
votre vraie nourriture à vous c'est quoi
c'est l'art c'est le jeu ce sont ces
rôles ça aussi c'est une question qui
est assez déchirante mais je vais pas
pleurer pour expliquer que oui je bouffe
des rôles je bouffe des pièces je bouffe
des films je bouffe on bouffe bien là en
ce moment dans les pigeons parce que la
nourriture des pigeons est très bne mais
c'est surtout que ça se partage je n'ai
jamais de ma vie voulu bouffer seul en
plus je bouffe très mal comme comme la
façon dont j'interprète les rôle je fout
tout dedans dès la première scène alors
à chaque fois le mé me dit bon peut-être
tu t'arrêtes là va pas plus loin tu as
mis tout le rôle bon mais justement tu
bouffes et ce que j'aime c'est le
partage c'est-à-dire d'avoir quelqu'un
ça va être paradoxal hein surtout que
les gens pensent que j'ai la grosse tête
que je suis là que je donne des leçons
et cetera pas du tout c'est que je suis
un enfant quand je suis sur le plateau
parce que je veux savoir ce que le
public ressent si je ne ressens pas que
le public pisse de rire ou que le public
s'emmerde ou que le public colère ou qui
si je le sens pas pour moi j'ai raté
mais ça doit arriver il doit y avoir des
soirs où c'est plus difficile que
d'autres ça ne réagit pas comment vous
faites dans ce cas-là alors voilà ce
qu'il faut bien savoir c'est que les
comédiens sont des baratineurs des
menteurs et alors moi le premier ça
n'est jamais arrivé j'ai fait que des TR
merveilleux al la question ne se pose
pas non mais des fois tu sors de mais
c'est comme quand on fait l'amour c'està
dire que des fois tu crois que c'était
formidable et en fait çait pas du tout
pour l'autre et et là tu crois tout d'un
coup en sortant de scène qu'est-ce que
tu as été mauvais puis tu as le mé en
scène qui est là comme ça enfin tu as
compris alors tu fais ouais ouais c'est
ouais vos parents n'étaient pas du tout
dans les métiers du spectacle votre père
Charles était directeur commercial d'une
marque de voiture votre mère Suzette
était couturière tous les deux Juifs
d'Europe de l'Est le goût du spectacle
vous est venu je crois de votre
grand-mère M m rose et l'histoire est
très jolie je crois qu'elle vous emmenit
vous et vos cousins et cousines tous ces
petits enfants en cachette au cinéma le
jeudi qui était le jour non le mercredi
parce que le jeudi c'était le le jour
libre à cette à cette époque là et donc
le mercredi soir mais moi elle m'a
presque toujours oui j'ai pas souvenir
emmené seul parce que j'avais l'air à 15
ans 16 ans d'en avoir 20 et tellement
j'étais comme ça rigide et donc j'allais
voir avec elle des films interdis au
moins de 16 ans c'est comme ça que j'ai
vu et ce sont les premières fesses de
femmes que j'ai vu celle de Brigitte
dans en cas de malheur avec gamin et et
et et puis c'est là où j'ai commencé
grâce à ma
grand-mère
à à me prendre pour un héros c'està-dire
que je trouve que à cette époque- là et
il avait tort le cinéma à cette époque
là on magnifiait que les héros alors
évidemment ils étaient sublimement beaux
sublimement forts il gagnaient toujours
à la fin des western tu tuis le méchant
et cetera et tout et petit à petit j'ai
commencé à me prendre pour un héros dans
la vie est-ce que ça a été une sorte de
refuge aussi dans dans dans la fiction
dans une fiction qui é peut-être plus
joyeuse que la réalité est-ce qu'il y a
eu de cela c'est une question super
incroyable parce que en fait c'est le
contraire du refuge quand tu quand tu es
en refuge tu es seul avec toi-même moi
j'ai jamais voulu être je ne voulais
plus jamais de ma vie j'ai failli mourir
j'ai je donc terminé après 10 après
quand j'ai eu 10 ans le viol et tout le
reste je me suis dit non je ne resterai
jamais tout seul avec moi je ne veux pas
justement être en refuge je veux être
avec les aut autres mais attention
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire les autres ça
veut dire que bien sûr j'avais des
copains qui venaient et puis on fait on
faisait plein de jeux et C des jeux
deséchec surtout et tout mais mon refuge
il était avec les auteurs c'estàd que
j'allais sous le lit le drap par-dessus
la tête et avec ma lampe de poche je
lisait les Shakespeare les Molières les
les les ronsards les rabets les les les
girodou les tout et c'était avec eux
donc et et d'ailleurs j'ai jamais
travaillé chez moi c'estàdire que je me
lève le matin très tôt 6h du matin c'est
obligatoire je sais pas pourquoi et et
puis je bon je me lave je prends la
douche hop mes affaires mes affaires je
F tout en vrac et je vais dans la rue et
tous mes textes je les ai appris en
montant et en descendant les
ChampsÉlysées et tous les trucs que j'ai
écrit c'est dans les café c'est dans les
trains j'apprends extraordinairement
c'est drôle quand ça bouge quand ça fuit
je ne peux pas rester statique j'ai
jamais appris un texte sur une scène de
théâtre à la lueur de celui que vous
êtes aujourd'hui Francis Huster quel
conseil donneriez-vous au petits garçons
qu'il était et quel qu'est-ce que vous
lui diriez avant qu'il ne se lance dans
la
vie je vous allez pas me croire mais
c'est la vérité ce que je me suis dit la
seule chose qui existe pour
toi c'est les femmes tu trouveras tout
chez les femmes et chaque pièce de
théâtre c'est comme la terre c'est
féminin c'est une pièce c'est pas un
pièce et toi tu es une personne tu es
pas un personne tu es féminin tu n'es
pas homosexuel tu pourrais être
homosexuel tu n'es pas alors elle donc
tu n'attendras d'amour de et surtout de
vérité que chez les femmes c'està-dire
que paradoxalement je me suis toujours
très très bien entendu avec les mecs
parce que quand tu t'entends pas avec
tes c'est fini casse-toi on est plus
copain mais avec les femmes j'ai jamais
su m'y prendre parce que il y a qu'à
lire les textes de toutes les héroïnes
dans les pièces elles disent la vérité
c'estàd elles disent la vérité sur ce
qu'elles pensent elles osent le dire
alors que les hommes ils sont nés
menteurs ils resteront menteurs ils ont
confondu justement le mensonge avec le
bouclier c'està-dire que pour eux mentir
c'est pas pour faire du mal c'est pour
se protéger les femmes elles se
protègent pas votre envie de jouer
Francis Huster vous mène au cours
Florent on en a parlé au Conservatoire à
la Comédie Française formation au
théâtre classique on va poursuivre cet
échange avec un document que j'ai à vous
prop posé qui a été délivré par nos
partenaires les Archives nationales nos
partenaires sur cette émission il s'agit
du devis de commande du décor d'une
comédie de Molière intitulé au départ
donjuan ou le Festin de Pierre plus
connu ensuite avec le titre abrégé
donjuan ce document date du 3 décembre
1664 jour où un marché a été passé au
domicile de Molière entre les comédiens
de la troupe et deux peintres
spécialisés pour la réalisation de décor
spectaculaires tous accepteront de payer
une somme très importante pour offrir au
public un grand spectacle avec des
machines ce qui était un peu nouveau
vous qui aimez tant Molière vous dites
quoi que Molière apporté encore bien
plus que des textes il a il a modernisé
le
théâtre cette pièce a été un échec
retentissant h 17 représentations pour
des qu ou C plus grands chef-dœuvres de
l'histoire du théâtre pourquoi parce que
Molière et c'est pour ça qu' qu'il aura
sa place au Panthéon et qu'il y sera
c'est tout simplement que Molière au
lieu de de
déclamer au lieu de distancier l'acteur
au théâtre justement Molière il a parlé
des gens de la rue il a parlé des gens
qu'on ne mettait jamais sur les rois les
seigneurs les dieux tout ça ça n'existe
pas lui il a non seulement la langue de
la rue c'est pour ça dit que le français
est la langue de Molière comme en
Angleterre l'anglais la langue de
Shakespeare mais surtout ce qui est le
génie de Molière c'est qu'il nous a
donné une arme que personne ne nous
avait donné nous le peuple c'est
extraordinaire de faire 10 ans de cursus
d'école et de et que les professeurs ne
puissent pas faire comprendre ça aux
élèves alors voilà on va faire un buzz
énorme cette arme que Molière nous a
donné qui n'est absolument pas ni dans
la tragédie ni dans les c'est le
rire
c'està-dire que c'est pas le rire
moqueur parce que quelqu'un se pète la
figure sur une peau de banane parce que
quelqu'un dit une bêtise non il nous a
donné une arme qui est qui a fait de la
France vraiment la lumière du monde
c'est de rire ce que personne n'avait
pensé de nous-même de nous-mêm
c'estàdire que tous les héros de Molière
sont vraiment des tordus c'est des sales
types Harpagon est un avar judin Jourdin
mais une saloperie qui veut se taper une
fille de la cour
il en a rien à de C rien à
que tu mêes je fou tout seul ce pays est
un pays de salot tous les rôles de
Molière donjo il tue les mecs il prend
leurs femmes il les épouse il les jette
tous les rôles de Molière pourquoi il a
fait ça parce que juste à côté du rôle
principal cette ordure il y a lui il y a
ganarel il y aapin il y a tous ceux qui
sont là et qui représentent le peuple a
les servantesor vous dites qu'il entrera
êesu ne CZ de demander vous AZ encore
appelé récemment Emmanuel Macron mais ça
n'arrive pas qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
ça vous a inspiré le fait que Emmanuel
Macron ne vous écoute pas et ne le fasse
pas entrer au pantéon alors justement
c'est la différence entre écouter et
entendre il m'a parfaitement entendu
parce qu'il m'a lui-même écrit de sa
propre main que mon combat était juste
et mais il ne m'a pas écouté tout
simplement parce que la règle du pantéon
c'est de mettre des artistes qui sont
nés après les lumières c'est ça la
justification c'estd que en fait la
République française depuis 5 République
elle a trahi sa propre morale en 1793 on
vole à Louis XV ce panthéon ce temple
qui aurait dû être un temple justement
pour l'honneur de tous les Français quel
qu'ils soi non on décide que c'est un
temple républicain pour ceux qui ont
servi non pas la France mais la
République car la preuve c'est que tout
ce qui s'est passé avant 1783 allez hop
à la poubelle donc ça veut dire que pour
alibi ils ont pris Voltaire qui n' de
républicain et Rousseau pour les faire
rentrer parce que eux étaient mort avant
mais tous tout c'est fini donc depuis
1793 ceux qui ont bâti la France qui ont
construit la France et sans sans
lesquels la République n'aurait jamais
existé ils ne sont pas célébrés au
pantthéon c'est absolument déloyal de la
part de la République donc il est
certain que la 6e République va se
construire c'est un buzz ça aussi la 6e
République on peut pas rester 100 ans
sur 195 58 on est déjà en 2023 mais
alors justement parlons un tout petit
peu de politique puisque vous êtes en
train d'aborder cette question des
politiques des puissants quel est votre
rapport à vous avec les puissants avec
les hommes et les femmes politiques vous
avez dit un jour je crois on ne peut pas
être artiste sans être de gauche une
phrase comme celle-ci quel est votre
rapport à cela aujourd'hui écoutez j'ai
eu des rapports très proches avec
beaucoup de présidents de la République
justement qui étaient tous je dois dire
que ce soit chira que ce soit mideran
que ce soit Sarkozi que ce soit Hollande
ils ont ils ont tous eu au contraire une
une pensée artistique pour faire avancer
dieu merci André malreux et Jacques Lang
ont été mais absolument exceptionnels
ils ont tenu bon le le le problème avec
la politique c'est que un un artiste
doit s'interdire de faire la politique
j'ai eu la prision quelquefois deux fois
d'être ministre de la Culture
oui je pas TR non mais non je veux pas
le dire parce que on parlera que de ça
mais ce que je peux dire c'est que ma
réponse comme administrateur de la
Comédie française c'est tout simplement
parce que je trouve que mon métier de
comédien il est justement en relation
d'amour et direct en chair humaine avec
le public et que l'homme politique au
contraire ou la ou la femme politique il
y en a qui l'ont fait merveilleusement
doit ils doivent se distancier pour ne
pas penser justement à l'humain ni au
présent mais à bâtir l'avenir et c'est
pour ça que je souhaite vraiment et
c'est ce qui va se passer c'est
évident ré av de la culture si vous
aviez accepté quelle aurait été votre
première mesure alors ma première mesure
c'est le théâtre obligatoire une fois
par semaine à la télévision de service
public en prime time une pièce de
théâtre 52 pièces par an et dans les et
dans les éc obligation tous les mois de
voir au moins une représentation
théâtrale aux élèves écoutez ils ont vu
des milliers de matchs de foot et il y
en a qui n'ont même pas vu C pièces de
théâtre parce que c'est pas la faute des
professeurs
j'ai des photos pour vous ça fait partie
des rituels de notre émission Francis
Huster si vous les acceptez évidemment
ce rituel des photos alors j'ai on en a
pas encore parlé mais vous êtes un grand
fan de foot et en particulier du PSG ça
donne quoi une soirée foot avec Francis
Huster ça trépigne ça je souvi de la so
bah oui ça ça trépigne c'est
insupportable insupportable avec Jacques
Villeray on voyait la demi-finale de
Coupe du monde où finalement la France
mène de deux buts en prolongation pu
finalement se faire monter t éliminé au
penalty ce que je veux dire sur le foot
plus c'est honte leot c'est le sport de
tricheur de menteur les maillots ils
font semblant d'être blessés ils
trahissent ils trichent ce qui n'est pas
du tout le rugby pourquoi j'adore le
football je respecte le rugby évidemment
pourquoi mais parce que c'est la vie et
que j'ai toujours dit à tous ceux qui
voulaient faire ce métier il faut
absolument que vous fassiez de choses
les échecs et le football le football
parce que vous comprenez que vous pouvez
pas jouer tout seul que vous avez des
partenaires
h att vousz c'estd tout coupz
jusémotion acteur dans la scène et que
vous l'ameniez jusqu'au bout bravo mais
vous pouvez rien sans les autres et
effectivement comme au football au
théâtre faut tricher faut faire attendez
je suis jamais mort sur une scène de
théâtre j'ai fait celui qui mourait tout
d'un coup j'ai eu des femmes dans dans
mes bras je les aimais pas amoureusement
et il fallait que je sois fou et
d'autres au contraire que je devais
détester et que j'adorais que que
j'aimais photo franc non pas du tout
mais j'avance c'est aussi mon rôle une
deuxième photo si vous l'acceptez
toujours Hollywood où a eu lieu une
grève historique des scénaristes au côté
d'ailleurs de quelques acteurs parmi
leurs sujets d'inquiétude les bas
salaires mais pas seulement et aussi
cette arrivée redouté par beaucoup de
l'intelligence artificielle qui pourrait
potentiellement remplacer en tout cas
mettre en péril le métier et la création
vous l'auriez faite vous cette grève
mais absolument j'aurais été à la
première ligne l'intelligence
artificielle l'intelligence artificielle
sublime tu es là tu es dans ta voiture
c'est la tu tournes à gauche ça
maintenant à droite mais tu peux très
bien t'arrêter puis dire non j'y vais
pas et je vais ailleurs voilà pourquoi
l'intelligence artificielle au-delà de
ses qualités extraordinaires d'accord
très bien audelà de sa complicité totale
avec les dictatures avec ceux qui s'en
serviront pour faire de tout le monde
des milliards de gens des esclaves mais
il y a une chose que l'intelligence aura
jamais c'est ce que je disais c'est le
doute c'estàd que comme elle ne doute
pas h elle elle ira directement jusqu'au
mur et elle deviendra comme les
bibliothèques dont on peut se servir les
encyclopédies les dictionnaires tout ce
que tu veux mais les hommes et les
femmes auront le dernier mot quand
Shakespeare dit être ou ne pas être la
plus célèbre réplique du monde entier
mais en fait ce que les gens ne savent
pas c'est qu'il y a un document où
Shakespeare avait pas mis que être ou ne
pas être il avait mis être ou ne pas
être être ou ne plus y êtrere ou ne plus
en être et puis il a enlevé ces deux là
pour laisser simplement être ou ne pas
être c'est tellement notre maître parce
que Shakespeare Molière c'est le cœur
bien sûr pour tous les Français mais
Shakespeare ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'il a défié Dieu h une dernière
question en lien avec notre lieu Francis
vous l'avez forcément remarqué nous
sommes entourés de quatre statutes très
imposantes dans ce lieu chacune
représente une vertu il y a la sagesse
la prudence
la justice et l'éloquence et le rituel
c'est de demander à notre invité en
laquelle de ces vertus il se reconnaît
est-ce qu'il y en a une dans laquelle
vous reconnaissez
aucune aucune la plus grande vertu du
monde c'est le
pardon et on s'arrêtera là sur ce très
beau mot merci merci francisuster
d'avoir été notre invité dans ce dô
tournau au Sénat le pardon donc et on
s'arrêtera sur ce mot merci infiniment
et merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
comme chaque semaine émission à
retrouver en podcast évidemment merci
beaucoup à
[Musique]
bientôt